All right. Now that quote's explained, why we want to use a more traditional
object-oriented class base set up, let's go ahead and do that. Now, we'll be
using a piece of code by John Resig that fakes class-based object oriented
programming. Feel free to take a look at the code or the linked blog below to
see how it works. Now, we're not terribly interested in the internals for our
purposes. What we care about is how to use it for instantiating the proper
class-based inheritance trees for our game objects. So, let's say we want to
create the following inheritance tree. We want weapon and entity to both inherit
from Class. And we want MachineGun and ChainGun to inherit from Weapon. And
Teleporter and EnergyCanister to inherit from entity. Now we've started this off
for you, but we're going to have you complete this yourself. First, we set
weapon to be Class.extend. What this means is that weapon extends all of Class's
functionality, whatever that happens to be, and then adds it's own on top of it.
Similarly, MachineGun is set to weapon.extend, which extends all of weapon's
functionality, and then builds on top of that. Now, we've created these for you
for a template. And, what I'd like you to do is fill in the rest of the
inheritance tree we discussed above.